STEPHANIE WONG: Your
cloud application
has a lot of data moving
over many parts of the public
and the private internet.
But what if you
want a heavier hand
in defining exactly what
paths your data can take?
In this episode of
Cloud Networking,
we'll talk about how
to define traffic
routing between networks.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One common problem
with networking
is that you need the ability
to link networks together
without allowing the data
to be visible to every user
in every location.
For example, let's say
company A and B share
a common wall in a
building and each
have their own private
networks, but then wish
to connect them together without
giving up their current network
configuration.
This would mean making both
networks use different IP
address ranges and
set up a router that
connects to both
of these networks
to pass traffic between them.
Traditionally,
setting up a router
for an on-premise
network requires
a fair bit of heavy lifting.
You physically assemble
these things together
to build interconnectivity
between users
and the applications they used.
Implementing all of this
could take days or even weeks.
And as the network grows,
the associated management
and cost to operate it also
grows disproportionately
larger for your company.
But with Google Cloud Platform,
software-defined routing
means every VPC network uses
a scalable Distributed Virtual
Routing mechanism.
GCP routes define the paths
network traffic takes from a VM
instance to other destinations.
These destinations can be
inside your VPC network--
for example, in another VM--
or outside of it.
Even though some routes
can be applied selectively,
the routing table
for a VPC network
is defined at the global
VPC network level.
Let's take a closer look.
Every route consists
of a destination
and a next hop, which are
IP addresses or ranges of IP
addresses.
Traffic whose destination IP
is within the destination range
is sent to the next
hop for delivery.
Each VM instance
has a controller
that's kept informed
of all its routes
from the network's
routing table.
Each packet leaving a VM
is sent to the next hop
of an applicable route
based on a routing order.
When you add or delete a
route, the set of changes
is propagated to
the VM controllers
using an eventually
consistent design.
This means that
you have simplicity
and centralized control, a
high degree of automation,
built-in security
and encryption,
and high [? performance. ?]
Now, there are two types
of routes on a GCP VPC--
system-generated routes
or custom routes.
System-generated routes give
you a default route and subnet
route.
The default route defines a
path for traffic from your VPC
to Google services and
the public internet.
The subnet route defines
a path for your traffic
into your VPC to each subnet.
This is how VPC peering works.
VPC peers always exchange
all subnet routes.
Custom routes mean you create
static routing yourself
or dynamic routes using
Google Cloud Router.
Let's walk through a
static route setup.
Here, I have two VPCs set up
in US east and US central.
I also set up a VPN
gateway on both sides
and created two IPSec
tunnels between them.
I have an Ohio server
in the US East VPC
and a warehouse server
in the US central VPC.
But I still can't ping the
internal IP of the warehouse
server from the Ohio server.
I need to create
two static routes
to enable traffic to be
forwarded into the tunnel.
We have default routes
created for each network,
but we're going to create
custom static routes.
First, let's create a
route from east to central.
Click CREATE ROUTE.
Specify a name for the route.
Select an existing network
where the route will apply.
The Destination IP range is
a central subnet internal IP
range.
I'll skip Priority
for now, but you
would use this to
determine routing order
if routes have the
same destinations.
Select a target
instance tag, or leave
it blank to apply the route to
all instances in the network.
Select a Next hop for the route.
I'll select my VPN tunnel.
And click Create.
Now, I'll create another
route for traffic
from central to east.
And voila, I can now ping the
internal IP of the warehouse
server from the Ohio server.
Keep in mind that
with static routes,
you have to create or
maintain a routing table.
And a topology change
on either network
requires you to manually
update static routes.
Also, static routes can't
automatically reroute traffic
if a link fails.
But static routing is
perfect for small networks
with stable topologies.
There's so much more I
can say around routing,
but it's clear that
Google's virtual routing
is what connects all the
moving pieces between subnets
and a VPC, and even to your
local network on-premise.
Stay tuned for more
networking end-to-end.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]